The joe rogan experience.
And the one thing that I noticed,
and I've said it before is like,
and I feel like other people have noticed this it cause I've gotten a lot of
fights when I was young,
but I don't think I ever won one.
And I feel like I must exude this kind of waft of something that like I just am
not a fighter,
but every time I've gotten in a fight it's been more that someone has,
I feel like it's taking,
trying to take advantage of me or has been picking on me for a long period of
time.
And it's the only way that this is going to stop or have been or have been
picking on someone that I cared about.
And,
and I always got the sense afterwards that the person who beat me up basically a
new what?
New?
That they're like they,
I can draw Davidson into a fight and I'll,
and,
and he'll,
he'll only go in,
he'll go into the bear trap and then I'll just be able to beat him up.
And the only good thing about it ultimately is that they,
the picking on stuff stopped,
you know what I mean?
But I had to take a beating in order to sort of affect that,
you know?
Yeah.
That's a weird psychological sort of a relationship between the bully and the
person who gets picked on.
Yeah.
But I feel like,
and I feel like the real true fighters wouldn't even do something like that.
They would recognize,
you know,
this guy or I'm not going to bother with this guy.
I mean the I am mother.
Yeah.
I mean,
May,
may,
I don't know.
Maybe,
maybe there are some fighters who liked to beat the shit out of people or you
sit,
yeah,
yeah.
You've,
I'm even noticing fight.
Sometimes I feel like that guy looks like he probably might have,
would be happy to be beating up someone with far less skill.
He'd be taking as much delight in it as he is.
Usually they've been abused.
Is that so,
yeah.
I believe that's a big part of,
uh,
a lot of what,
what constitutes a bully is physical abuse.
You know that they've been abused either at home or they've been abused by other
kids and they're trying to lash out and get theirs.
Now they've sort of taken on the role of the bully because they've been bullied
so much.
That happens a lot.
I could see that.
I actually,
here's the,
here's the sort of a story of my,
one of my,
my worst beatings.
Uh,
I was at the YMC,
hey,
me and my brother were playing basketball.
That was probably like I 16,
17,
eight towns might in my last year of high school probably.
And uh,
these two guys come and say,
let's,
let's play two on two.
So we did,
and back then I probably weighed like two 40.
I was,
I was a big fat dude.
You know,
I just see it.
40 in high school.
Yeah.
Maybe,
maybe,
maybe two 30.
Like I was enormous,
but it was not a,
it was not a healthy weight.
Obviously that's what you weigh now.
One 75 one that,
that's partly the whole boxing stuff.
And we do tree planting a lot up in Canada.
That's sort of like what you do at university.
You just go up to the woods and plant trees and that.
I shed a lot of weight that way,
uh,
during,
during university,
but,
so I was a big beast,
you know,
when I started,
knew how to use my body and the guy that I was playing against was maybe one,
one 60.
Um,
so we're getting close to beat them.
And I turned around and I see the ball,
it's a whipping right at my face.
He'd thrown it at me and I turned my head and it sort of goes by the side of my
head and just,
you know,
gives me a scalp burn basically.
And then he's,
then he's charging right at me,
like to get no fight.
Um,
and there was no pro prior provocation.
None at all.
That's the thing.
I mean,
this guy just to basketball,
just a basketball game and,
and,
okay.
It's in the why.
So I'm like,
okay,
well we're not going to have a fight right in the middle of the why.
I think I'm going to be okay.
That's,
I mean,
I didn't really want to get into a fight,
but again,
this guy throwing a basketball,
I mean it's pretty shitty move.
So anyways,
this guy comes out,
he's gotta be like 80 years old.
He's like one of those guys at the y that was like a retired gym teacher and
they sort of said,
okay bill,
um,
you can just start hang out around here and keep order.
That's the be nice of you to do that.
So he comes out and he's got a whistle around like an old p whistle around his
neck.
He says,
take it outside.
I'm like,
I don't,
the last thing I want to do is take this outside,
but,
and,
and he says,
that's it guys.
You take this outside.
So I'm like,
oh sh I'm sort of like being shoe horned into going out to having a fight with
this guy.
So I'm going down the hallway and my brother is,
it's like out of a raw,
he should,
he's massaging my shoulders cause I guess he thinks that's what he should be
doing.
You know,
that's how it's a little,
we know about fighting.
You know what I mean?
He's,
my brother was like,
well,
I guess I've seen this in rocky.
I should keep him,
keep him limber and you know,
he's like,
oh,
you're,
you're going to be fine.
And if I,
but I had a chance to look in his eyes,
he'd be like,
you are,
you are fucked.
You know what I mean?
And I think I knew that too.
So I ended up outside,
it's winter in Canada and uh,
there's ice on the,
on the,
on the sidewalk and you know,
I,
I face up and what I assume is somewhat somewhat of a fighting posture.
And he kicks me in the head.
It's a first thing he does just like kicks me right in the head.
And I'm not even sure what that will happen.
I'm still standing,
you know,
and they need does it again.
And then I'm like,
Oh God,
this is not,
this is not good.
So he had martial arts training.
Auslan.
Yeah,
definitely.
And then,
you know,
there was a bike rack and I remember he like rang my,
my head off of it and I'd get them in a,
you know,
sort of a headlock.
And,
uh,
and I remember being like face down and there's like ice melts on the street,
you know,
that those blue crystals they put down,
and I'm,
I'm,
my face is pressed into it and thankfully it goes on for awhile.
Clearly I'm,
I'm beat.
And he's like,
are you,
are we,
are we had enough here?
I'm like,
yeah,
I mean,
I've,
I've had enough,
that's enough.
So he goes back inside chuckling with his buddy.
Um,
I'm sitting out there on the street bleeding.
I don't even want to go back into the why,
you know what I mean?
I'm going to have the people inside going,
what the hell happened?
Do you need help?
And I'm like,
I just want to crawl into a hole and,
you know,
not see humanity for about a month.
Uh,
saw my brother goes inside,
gets my clothes,
we go,
I find out later this guy,
we lacrosse is a big sport in our,
in our country.
And he was like the enforcer on the Lacrosse Lacrosse team,
like the triple a Lacrosse team.
So he was a tough guy.
Like I didn't have a chance,
you know,
right from the get go.
I didn't have a chance.
And then,
you know,
I discover his name cause we lived in a small town.
And you sort of,
these things sort of come to you.
Uh,
as time goes by and then,
um,
my buddy calls me up,
but a couple of years later he says,
you hear about so and so?
I said,
no,
I was away at university at this point.
He's like,
they went camping in the woods and hit him and his dad.
And this word gets back to your idea of abuse.
He stabbed his dad 44 times,
killed him,
killed him in the woods,
and they caught him just walking down the street with the knife in his hand.
And,
uh,
and you know,
later on the interview,
his mom and his mom was like,
yeah,
he was,
uh,
you know,
he basically would sit out on the porch saying that George Bush was going to
come in air force one anytime,
pick them up for some top secret missions.
So we clearly had some,
some mental instabilities that didn't present themselves at the age at which at
least they were maybe emerging,
but later use them.
I mean,
that part had never been been into,
I'm not,
I can't really comment on that,
but I mean,
I,
I don't know,
but I think I feel like he stabbed the man 44 times.
It would have to be a really heated argument.
And if they had no prior sort of history with one another,
I don't,
I don't really know.
But first of all that he stabbed him and then he stabbed him that many times.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
And I sort of thought later,
man,
as bad as I got it,
I mean,
I could've gotten a lot worse.
You know what I mean?
At least he like,
let me off at the end.
He's like,
all right,
well,
I always try to explain that someone who gives people the finger and a car,
like you never know who you're giving the finger to.
Exactly.
My,
my wife has a bad habit of honking the horn.
I'm like,
baby,
I love you,
but don't,
don't do it.
Don't do it.
Don't you don't know who the hell is stepping out of that freaking car.
You know?
Not only that,
you never know what state they're in.
They can be in the worst state of mind ever at the moment you lay on that horn,
you could have caught them at the breaking point.
Yeah,
and that's what puts them picked fucking people.
Especially in this day and age when you're dealing with cities and traffic and
the unnatural stress of slamming 200 fucking million people together like this.
Yeah.
Very nice.
You're like,
Oh shit,
I'm,
I'm up against a different breed of humanity,
right guys kicking me in the head and nowhere and you know,
you're just trying to play basketball and your brother's rubbing your shoulders.
Neither want to be know.
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh,
we're totally neo fights and,
and you know,
and there was something,
you know,
this is probably way too like writerly,
but there is something about the eyes of a guy like that,
that you're just like,
oh,
I'm,
you know,
you're done before you're done.
You're done before one thirds of those dudes.
Yeah.
There's just something clock working around it.
Their eyes,
and you're just like,
oh no,
no,
I'm not,
I'm not built to this standard.
This is not going to work out too well for me.
Okay.